blessé mais bien vivant après l'assaut
des policiers du raid le forcené a été
hospitalisé pour une simple fracture
épilogue d'une journée qui aurait pu
virer au drame tôt ce matin ce boulanger
du centre commercial auchan de saint cyr
sur loire s'était retranché dans son
commerce armé d'un fusil les détails
avec romain des tuiles
à 7h30 ce matin une salariée de la
boulangerie des gourmet de saint cyr
découvre le gérant un fusil de chasse
calibre 12 à la main dans un petit
bureau de l'établissement selon le
procureur de la république de tours le
boulanger qui a entretenu une relation
affective avec cette femme la menace est
elle enferme à 8 heures un périmètre de
sécurité est mis en place
les salariés présents quelques
commerçants sont évacués rapidement de
9h à 15h30 les policiers du commissariat
de tours puis les policiers du raid
négocié avec le boulanger compagnons du
devoir
ce que nous avons un individu retranché
et armés qui est dangereux pour lui même
et pour autrui il est systématiquement
fait appel aux forces d'intervention de
niveau 3 donc en zone police c'est le
raid qui a les capacités matérielles
humaines les compétences de négociation
pour essayer de convaincre ces individus
de se rendre et de les interpeller dans
les plus grandes conditions de sécurité
à 15h30 l'assaut est finalement lancé
les policiers font exploser la serrure
lance une grenade assourdissante
le boulanger est maîtrisée il aurait une
fracture au pied sans doute dû à
l'explosion cet homme de 44 ans respecté
dans la profession semble submergé par
des déboires personnels qui l'ont
conduit à cette situation mortifère il
semblait souffrir d'importants troubles
psychiatriques il était suivi à ce
niveau là et avait fait de nombreuses
tentatives de susciter on sait que
depuis le 16 mai il avait disparu et
qu'une procédure en disparition
inquiétante était actuellement en cours
au commissariat de police de tours et
que personne entre le 16 mai aujourd'hui
n'avait une nouvelle de lui la sûreté
départementale de tours est chargée de
l'enquêté pour tentative d'homicide
volontaire par conjoint le boulanger a
été transportée à l'hôpital pour être
soigné ou sa garde à vue va lui être
notifiée